good morning everybody
welcome to this joint audit and
standards committee i am councillor bryn
haron and i am chair in the meeting
today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use that you do
not interrupt other speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
and please ensure your mobile phones are
on silent or twitched off
i would like to remind everyone present
this morning that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
introductions today the officers
attended the meeting are john snell
corporate manager for internal audit
risk and data protection
uh sue palmer senior finance business
partner capital and treasury and mandy
smith who's the governance officer today
we have had apologies from melissa evans
can i now move to the agenda please
apologies for abstinence and any
substitutions mandy uh we have received
apologies from councillor heirs and
councillor caston um and there are no
substitutions today
okay thank you for that
um any declarations of interest for
today's meeting
we're all clear thank you
uh any
sorry moving to the agenda confirmation
of the minutes of the meeting um we have
got two
actually to do um
held on the 29th of november first that
one i was
present for that one so i'm quite
willing to
propose that
and are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes first
for those who were here
okay fine well i'll ask for a second to
please
dave thank you councillor muller
and i'll ask mandy to the governance
officer to conduct the votes
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress on the app can i take your vote
verbally
abstain okay thank you
um
thank you everybody
thank you chair that's uh four votes
four and three abstentions so that's
passed
okay
thank you jeff oh thank you mandy um
item four
the minutes again jac 2130
confirmation confirmation of the minutes
on the 28th of march
22
not quite as long ago
but um
yeah councillor muller is proposing
and a seconder from the floor somebody
was here
councillor norris thank you very much
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress councillor norman
thank you
make a chair that again is four votes
four and three abstentions so that's
passed as well
thank you very much
and notification of
petitions do we have any
no petitions received
questions from the public no questions
received
questions by councillors no questions
received
we are getting an easy ride today we
moved to the um
the beef of the agenda jac 2131 held
over from last time the
inter annual internal audit report um
gonna invite jon snell to present please
thank you john
thank you chair and good morning members
ready the purpose of the report in front
of you is to provide you with details of
the work undertaken
by internal audit for the year 2122
which is required under the public
sector internal audit standards
the report also details the view of
other corporate activities
which are supported by the work of the
team during last year
there are a number of sort of key
messages that i'd like to get across to
you
to draw out and tease out from the
report and these include
excuse me
the demand on internal audit services to
provide assurance support and advice
uh continues as the councils continue to
reshape and transform its services
in line with the council's internal
audit charter the work has been
conducted to ensure that it delivers
against the public sector internal audit
standards and the requirement for me is
the head of audit to provide
an annual audit year-end opinion
so what does our work cover
just running down some of the bits there
so in terms of work it's looking at the
governance processes and some of that
will be in more detail in the next paper
on the annual government statement
the monitoring arrangements across the
organization when we undertake the
audits that we do
some ethical values in terms of
behaviors cultures of the organization
information governance in terms of data
quality
data management
risk management
and fraud management
the work of the internal audit continues
to be resourced from existing staff and
from an external audit partner
this arrangement allows a direct
internal provision
plus the commissioning of external
skills and capacity and provides a blend
of resources from within the councils
and from the external partner itself
the option of working with an external
partner currently makes good sense and
it's something that is supported by our
slt our senior leadership team
and that management still remains
control over the internal audit function
while at the same time leveraging the
internal audit resources of the third
party provider
it provides us access to valuable and
diverse specialized skills as needed and
achieves a level of flexibility i think
which can be critical
in effectively dealing with a range of
operational issues that we face
moving through on to the appendix
a which is the main body of the report
itself
you'll see that the work undertaken that
of the completed audits only one
returned an ordered opinion on the
control environment of limited assurance
at the end of the last financial year
and again in line with our own internal
order procedures this audit will be
followed up and the outcome reported
back to this committee as part of the
midterm report later in the year
the full status of this report is
detailed in section six below with all
the other audits undertaken during last
year
as well as conducting audit reviews
internal audit had significant
involvement within a period in a variety
of different order activities
and these include leading on the
production of the annual governance
statement which i'll present after this
report
attending the council statutory offices
working group and that's to provide a
professional determination on governance
matters as they arise
and as one of the two councils deputy
monitoring officers at the time
supporting emily as the monitoring
officer with specific duties to ensure
that the councils their officers and
elected members maintain the highest
standards and of conduct in all that
they do
full details of the anti-fraud and
corruption work undertaken during the
year is only reported to this committee
and the last report was presented to you
in march of this year
until recently internal audit had been
part of the council's tactical
management team responsible for managing
emerging risks
and directing resources to help ensure
critical services are maintained across
the two districts
our professional insight is now called
upon when required
a member of my team continues to support
the council's business sale
by providing assurance over the
administrating of the various business
grants
schemes announced by central government
and more recently the energy rebate
payment
that work includes ensuring that the
prescribed criteria in terms of
eligibility is correctly applied and
meets the managing issues around fraud
and also available digital uh tools that
we use to help identify potential fraud
through spotlight and the national fraud
initiative initiation platform
in terms of performance uh through the
year the completed customer service
surveys which our audit clients continue
uh can complete continue to express a
high level of satisfaction with a
service delivered with 80 of the
completed audits being rated as either
excellent and 20
being rated as good
you'll see from the statistics there
within the report that only 50 percent
of the customer surveys
were returned
and that's something as the head of
order i'm trying to increase
what normally happens is at the end of
any audit
a customer service is provided to the
key contact of that audit they complete
it and obviously then i monitor the
feedback given
in terms of chase up
our section would only probably email
once as a chase up and we don't follow
up further
but what i will try and do certainly for
this financial year is ensure that that
50 is increased to a higher a higher
return rate
you also see that internal audit
continues to perform well against degree
key performance indicators
you'll see from the table that the
reduced percentage of the audit plan
delivered is a result of management's
requests for internal audits continual
support to provide a level of assurance
to the business sale responsible for the
administration of business grants and
payments which i mentioned earlier
in terms of the annual audit opinion
as head of audit i am satisfied that
sufficient assurance work has been
carried out which will allow me to form
a reasonable conclusion on the adequacy
and effectiveness of each of the
council's internal control environment
is therefore my opinion that the
council's framework of governance risk
management and internal controls are
deemed to be reasonable assurance
i.e this means the system process or
activity achieves its objectives safely
and effectively
however with any of the audits that we
undertake there will be some control
weaknesses and these are reported
where they're not
operating effectively
however what i would say is those
weaknesses that have been identified
through the audit review
we work very closely with senior
management to ensure that appropriate
corrective actions are taken and a time
scale for improvement is implemented
there are no audit related issues that
currently need to be brought to your
attention through this report so i'm
happy to take any questions at this
stage
thank you john um just before i open the
floor for questions um
i note your remarks when you chase up
for sort of opinion and that's all from
people within this organization i
presume or mainly from people within
this organized organization is that
correct
sideshow yes that's taken from the
internal audit plan that you um actually
approve at the beginning and again
that's also subject to consultation with
slt as well so
this report is based on that plan as i
said there's a couple of audits that
were deferred and that's a result of the
work continual work that we've been
asked to do on those business grants
yes okay what i make is it ought to be
reasonably easy to get the um
uh the number of answers up a bit i
would have thought you know it's not as
if you're um appealing to people from
outside the organization it's mainly
within so
yeah i mean i could take a view in the
sense that if we don't get a response
it's a positive response that makes
sense um but certainly in terms of the
openness and things that we can learn
from the internal audit review process i
am as i say to increase that 50 percent
yeah it would be nice to know
okay um i'll open this paper up now to
questions from
councillors before we go to debate
who wants to be first um councillor
norris please
thank you chair
excuse me
uh page 26 planning enforcement of
limited assurance follow-up audit plan
for completion and end of july 2022-23
perhaps i missed this my hearing is not
as good as it used to be um could you
give us an update on what the current
position is on this because this is one
of the areas that the public are
more concerned with i think than
anything else
thank you
thank you councillor um we're at the
point where we're having discussions
with phil isabel who's has such
responsibility for enforcement action so
we've undertaken the work and there are
a couple of points for clarification
more than anything that we just need to
take up with phil and his team before we
issue the report as a draft to get
management responses
and a final but it's actually imminent
but obviously i'll report that back at
midterm report which is sort of november
time
but yes that report is actually
amendment councillor
councillor bonn
um thank you chair um thank you um john
for your report um i've got quite a few
questions um shall i just do three up
first thank you
hopefully they're quick
um thanks on on page um so i've got
notes on my old one as well as the new
one so paige i think it's 23 of the new
papers contract management um it says to
consider social value in the audit but i
my understandings we don't actually
measure social value at the moment so i
just wondered how that is is how you
assess that
um
secondly on corporate um
[Music]
procurement
also not on
um
on um the budgeting budgetary control
on pages of 23 to 24.
there isn't an opinion given in the
final column so um
i just wondered what
um i think a lot of us have had concerns
about
budgetary process so i just wanted to
get um what assurance you were giving or
not or whether it's further work as it
says there
and
just my third one in risk management
which is page 24
is there going to be any more resource
on risk management
i've got a couple more questions chair
but if i come back after other people
have asked thank you
yeah thanks thank you captain i
appreciate three questions at the time
because my brain wouldn't with anything
else
in terms of the first question around
social value
social value at the time
when we first started looking at this
several years ago was sort of a
heightened awareness in terms of
ensuring where we were going out to
contract
we were looking at
perhaps looking at more localized
contracts that we could do to enhance
the economic environment around the two
district councils in terms of social
values in terms of how we were going to
apply those but you're quite right i
think there's a sort of slight change in
emphasis on social value that it's not
so easy to actually measure
and that's something that we are working
with melissa who's unfortunately not
here and the cnp team which is the
commissioning procurement team and how
they actually address those issues and
whether it's something that from an
internal audit point of view and also
from you as members point of view
whether you'd like assurances around
that aspect of social value and how we
could apply it um certainly with the
existing contract and moving forward
with new contracts
the second point about budget control
where there's no opinion
this piece of work was
discussed with the then section 151
officer catherine steele
also with melissa
and
what
they wanted was there there was a
recognition that the budget control
processes weren't robust
or as strong as they might be
so he wanted a consultation piece of
work around the whole process
so it wasn't necessarily would have been
in the audit plan but it was something
that was requested by catherine
supported by melissa so instead of
giving an order opinion we've deemed it
to be constant
consultative so our external audit
provider have a wealth of knowledge
across
a wide breadth of clients
who were brought in to undertake that
work which was well received by
catherine and also melissa and as you
can see within the report we're going to
be doing some further work with melissa
to help further support that whole
budgetary process uh and sue
is here as well but um sue is one of the
key people that we were speaking to as
part of that whole process as well
and i think your last question was
around risk management
and
as you'll see that
my role has changed in the sense that
within the report you'll see that we
have now a
dedicated team which
encompasses
performance risk
insight and policy and that's headed up
by a new interim corporate manager and
one of the recommendations that tier the
external audit provider said is that
effectively we didn't have enough
resources within my own team
that was then decided well managing
management decided to move this
management across to this new area and
they i understand they've just appointed
a full-time risk management officer
unfortunately i never had that luxury
when it was with me
so quite envious in many ways but
hopefully that gives you
some assurance that there's a dedicated
officer at a higher grade as well
that will be undertaking that work
um thank you very much for that um
just on the budget um budgetary control
will we be
will you be then following that up and
will we then see that again and if i may
just ask another question then i'll wait
for others um on on the health the
housing health and safety follow-up um
just who who is monitoring the time
frame for improvements there
because
in terms of the concerns that raised
thank you
the budgetary process what we don't want
to do is come into an area or appear
where it's extremely busy but you will
obviously see the outcome of that
and i think the next question we're
talking about
so please bear with me a second on the
housing
bottom of page 27. oh lovely thank you
okay so you can see that
it came out the audit opinion was
reasonable assurance
we were working closely at the time with
uh gavin who has since departed across
to ipswich borough um
my understanding is that's now left in
the capable hands of those corporate
managers
and i think i'm right in saying that
emily a tack is acting as
head of housing in the interim uh until
that's been formally
filled
so those
areas which
are very important in terms of
compliance are being dealt with
and implemented by those corporate
managers responsible under those
compliance checks
other questions from the floor
but just to give you a break rachel um i
was going to ask question um john on the
climate change sort of um
role
um
now you've been doing that for a while
is it getting more robust as time goes
on and it seems to be um
ever more urgent or is it something you
do sort of on a yearly basis and then
just
leave i i think you're going to say not
it's a rolling program isn't it but um i
i think i just want reassurance that we
are taking it seriously really that's
probably um what the basis of my
question is
yeah certainly and again unfortunately
cass has departed but cass clements who
was the director responsible for climate
change
we
again it was a piece of work that our
external provider did
provider provided in the sense that
climate change is quite a specialized
area even for auditors it's relatively a
new area and we didn't have the internal
audit experience hence why we've moved
to the external provider to
to give that
overview and again it came out as
reasonable assurance and when you look
at the findings there's quite a bit of
sort of uh areas for sort of improvement
but not significant areas that would
cause concern but there was also some
very good practice that was identified
particularly with the environmental
delivery plan and also the carbon
production plan so
it's something that
is never off our agenda it's not in the
plan to do this year but it would be
something that i would think we would be
revisiting from an audit purpose just to
see how that plan has developed and
whether we're going to meet those
milestones particularly as we move
forward to 2023
so yes
yeah thank you for that john
back to you um councillor rebomb um
thank you chair it was just a kind of i
mean i apologize i haven't been on this
committee for a while um
um so new back onto it but just in in
paragraph 4.4 when you look at
what the work has to cover you know it
talks about governance processes
monitoring and it says ethics and i just
wondered
kind of how that is looked at it's such
a
nefarious kind of area um is there a
particular framework or something that
helps
helps you and the team look at that or
just
to give me some or give us as it were
some understanding on that thank you
very much
again thank you for uh it's a very good
question in terms of ethical because
ethics generally is a huge wide
encompassing area it's a bit like
governance what does governance mean
what does ethics mean
so what we tend to do with big areas
like that is have a look at more of a
holistic approach so when we're
undertaking audits we might look at the
behaviors of individuals officers key
officers and also the cultures so we
have our five values that we're all
signed up to are they demonstrating that
within their work and how they conduct
themselves either with yourselves either
with external bodies and also within the
teams themselves
one of the ethical standards that we're
looking at for this year for example is
around gifts and hospitality
so
what's the again the culture within the
organization
do we
discourage it do we encourage it how is
it reported how is it recorded the same
with hospitality as well
it's a big area not you know in national
politics as well as small politics
so they're the types of areas that we
would look at and focus on for a
specific piece of work
there is a school of thought as well and
i've been mulling this one over about
doing an ethical audit which might be
challenging
so we're looking at all sorts of areas
so if we're taking the constitution
how do we apply the constitution how do
we monitor it how do we report on
breaches of that constitution is
everybody aware of the risk management
processes that are in place
around counter fraud aspects
whistleblowing so that's all to do with
behaviors and the culture of the
organization
and what was in the back of my mind
though i need to sort of refine it
slightly is as we're moving forward is
actually to do perhaps a survey to raise
awareness and what do people understand
do they know where the risk management
strategy is for example did they know
about whistleblowing do they know about
anti-fraud and corruption arrangements
do they know about the gifts in the
hospital hospitality so if they don't
then we need to actually educate members
of staff and there are same members as
well so we're all signed up to it so
it's not just officers
so that's something that i will probably
be looking at more closely next year
is because i sometimes wonder how um
organizations seem to go completely off
the rails sometimes it seems to be
systemic and um that's very very
reassuring john that it's not likely to
happen here
other members
any points before we go to debate
questions
no we will move to debate i'm um
i've read this through twice now once in
july and once
now and um there's just been minor
changes but i'm happy and we'll be happy
to um propose this if we get that but
any um into debate any other points um
councillor muller
yeah yes i'd like to thank john for his
report it's an excellent report
and i'm more than happy to if you're
happy to propose the recommendation 3.1
then i'm happy to second that chair
thank you
thank you
council rebound
um thank you chair yes now i think i
think a huge amount of work goes in here
so thanks to john and the team but um
i do think and i've raised the points
about social value and and ethics and i
do think those are areas where we need
to
really understand it and if there are
frameworks somewhere that we can
use borrow let's not reinvent the wheels
as to see how we're performing for our
residents
i think that will be really helpful but
i'm happy to support the recommendation
thank you chair okay
any other points to be raised in debates
now we have a
austin um councillor davis
i was just to also thank john for that
and uh make the observation that
whistleblowing is a way of helping
check the health of the organization and
giving people that reassuring feeling if
they
are not comfortable with something they
can easily raise it without fear of
persecution so i think that work would
be really invaluable but thank you for
all the hard work
thank you very much um councillor daves
i meant to welcome you to the meeting
because you had a false start last time
didn't you but welcome to the meeting
and welcome to um joint order and
standards committee any other points
before we move to the vote
no believe i'll ask the governance
officer to um
conduct the vote we have a proposal in
the second
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress on the app
councillor norman can i take it away
thank you
chair that's eight votes for so that's
unanimous
you members
and we move now to
jac 2133 the annual treasury management
report um
once again over to you john please
sorry was that the annual governance
report
i beg your pardon the annual government
statement yes
my apology 2132
went through a blind panic there
[Laughter]
just checking you're awake but you
obviously are
okay thank you chair um yeah hugely
important uh report so um it reviews
each council's corporate governance
arrangements during 2122
and this is required by the accounts and
audit regulations and is presented as a
joint statement to reflect the
government's arrangements in place
across both councils
furthermore it provides an insight
looking ahead for this year and the key
challenges facing both councils moving
forward as well as addressing those
challenges identified during 2021 and
any resultant actions taken from that
this committee has a huge responsibility
um for being satisfied that the
statement properly reflects the
government's arrangements in place as
they've as they see it and that hasn't
experienced it as
councillors baber and mid-suffolk have
adopted the local code of corporate
governance that sets out a commitment
to corporate governance generally and
summarizes the governance arrangements
and activities in place to which it's
accountable and engages with its
communities
the local code is consistent with the
principles of the set for solace
framework delivering good governance in
local government which was first set out
in 2016.
the statement explains how the councils
have
complied with the local code
and also meets those requirements as
mentioned before about
from the accounts and audit regulations
2015.
to reflect the code the ahs includes
assurance statements from various
offices including myself
which represent the oversight's
functions and again forms which helps
forms this opinion for my previous
report the senior leadership have also
had the opportunity to view and comment
on the ags as part of the review process
and their comments have been
incorporated within the statement that
you have before you today
the ahs provides an assurance the
effectiveness of the council systems on
internal control the arrangements
continue to be regarded as fit for
purpose
in accordance with the governor's
framework
there have been no governance issues
identified during the year which are
considered significant in relation to
each council's overall governance
framework
the kovit 19 emergency has meant that
the councils had to make a number of
changes to its governance arrangements
during the years
the government statements provides
assurance to that effect over governance
arrangements that have been in place
during 2122
but it also identifies through the
assurance statements from officers or
issues and changes that have been
implemented in response to this
emergency
although the council's arrangements are
still under pressure they are less so as
we're coping much more with covid
so it's felt that the systems
are sufficient in terms of how robust
the governance arrangements and that
framework is in place currently
and again i'm happy to take any
questions as a result
right thank you john um
before we move to questions i think if
you look at the um
the intro page 40 um
4.2 it just sums up everything that we
do doesn't it um
we charge the governance is about the
council ensuring that we're doing the
right thing in the right way for the
right people and in a timely inclusive
open honest and accountable manner
it just covers everything that we do in
this whole council so it just um
shows you how serious we should all take
this
um
right from
beginning to end really so very very
important committee in a very very
important statement
so questions please
from the floor
councilory bond that's a good job you're
here isn't it well you know chair our
role is to kind of you know listen to
the um the
team that are putting these together and
actually ensure that ask questions to
ensure it's it's all robust so um
hopefully i'm doing that but anyway
um
i've got a series of questions but
they're mainly around how we how we we
budget for example on um
you know i know there's been issues in
the past and again it's identified here
about audit as in the financial audit
and who who audits the um council and
there have been a lot of issues with
that in the past and and i sort of
wonder where we're at whether we were
just going to stay with that so i'm
looking at sue a bit more here or
whether we're thinking of you know
changing that or um although i know it's
an issue with councils across england
um
and with regards to kind of
um
i've got sort of two areas of
issues there's one to do with budgets
for example on page 82 we talk about
explaining budget setting
um
and
i take that to be explaining it to the
community and to to residents and
i don't really see much of that so i
just wonder what the evidence of that is
apart from when people finally get a
council tax bill but that's that's
beyond budget setting that is once the
budget is is approved so um
you know
how are we showing about explaining
budget setting to our community
and um
with regards to
[Music]
the information that's
that's available internally
um
the the reference to sort of council
priorities and so forth um i think
that's page 68.
connect isn't up to date there are our
intranet is not up to date so how can we
be assured that all of the information
and i think we've all come to the point
where we go to the website on behalf of
a resident or whatever else or for our
own benefit and and find things that are
just
you know not 100 out not 100 up to date
so how do we ensure that that is the
is the case
um
and
finally chair if i may just stop this
it's virtually the last paragraph on
page
83
we talk about investing in
communications but we don't ever seem to
kind of
talk to our residents about things that
didn't go so well and therefore what
we're going to do to to change those we
only seem to talk about successes so and
i think that that is a key part of all
of this because we've got to be open and
honest
so just to get the view on that thank
you chair
for the first point i'm looking at sue
in obviously melissa's absence regarding
the budget setting process and how we
articulate that to our community i don't
know if you can answer that
no
right i think
cancer is a very good point i think what
i'll do in obviously melissa's absence
and if you is a a committee you're happy
um
it would be a question that needs to be
referred to melissa is unfortunately she
can't be here she's actually got covid
it's quite poorly so
um if we can defer that and i'll
through mandy clark we will address that
and ask minister to respond
to you as a committee i don't want to
say anything that
might
devalue what
melissa and her team are actually doing
to as i say to articulate that message
clearly to to our communities
in terms of i think your next question
was around about council robot connect
or whether it's uh or it's not up to
date
i will put my hand on heart and my page
isn't up to date
my role has recently changed
and
i have i suppose i'm quite pleased in
saying this i actually notified um the
officer response before updating connect
on my page
but i take your point that it's
not just connect and i think some of our
web pages need a total refresh
so i think that's something that needs
to be fed back to
i've seen a management
personally
and ensure for us as corporate managers
or me for corporate managers that um my
internet sorry my connect page intranet
page is up to date which it will be
within the next few days and that was
subject to some of my roles changing
and i think that can be spread right
across
the other offices to make sure that it's
up to date
and also from a wider perspective
certainly web pages need to be looked at
there's nothing worse
in trying to find something on our way
patient you can't find it or it's out of
date because that's frustrating and
that's in terms of our reputation that's
not particularly good so i think we can
take that away counsellor and
perhaps raise that through
our senior management to
disseminate that message
sorry and your last bit was on
communication so yeah we talk about
what's our successes and perhaps not so
much about not so well um i think i'm
not in position as the head of audit to
answer that question but i think maybe
that can go back to
the head of communications
and the director sarah wilcock who is
responsible for communications and feed
that back and
perhaps get a response again to to this
committee as a whole if that's okay with
you
um just particularly on the on the
internet because at the top of page 68
where it talks about that and it says
these are all available
best practice
all this information is regularly
monitored um
but but it isn't because we you know you
look to see what the council's
priorities are or or work going on and
you see things saying last updated 2021
or whenever it is
and
when we've when we ask for answers on
this we are told oh ignore that bit it's
this it's on somewhere else kind of
thing well that's
you know that that's
and my my concern is is i wouldn't be
confident in saying this is
you know this
is accurate because my own personal
experience is that it isn't
so and i just i i can and i am concerned
that we're not as an organization
ensuring that the information both
internally and externally
is is accurate
thank you
thank you councillor ebon i saw various
nods then and um
i also hear from feedback from customers
constituents that it's not um it's not
brilliant
does anyone else want to say a word on
this subject
council and norman
um thank you chair um yeah i would i
would just uh second exactly what
councillor um ebert said
um yeah essentially when i i've spoken
to a lot of residents that when they go
on the website they find that a lot of
information is up to date and i know um
on even our pages you know when you go
onto the sort of paper website and you
look at our pages and there's a lot of
information about me on sort of my
register of interest um that i've
updated and needs to be added on there
and some of that is from you know about
a year ago and it's still not up to date
so and obviously you can see on there
when it was last updated and i think i
can see that it was last updated sort of
when we were elected essentially so i
think just across the board obviously
there's bits on all parts of the website
that just just needs to be updated and i
think yeah it's very important that that
is thorough because obviously when we're
giving this information out to residents
and it comes back and it's not up to
date it kind of reflects badly on us as
well so yeah that is very important so i
just wanted to second the points there
okay well that will be minuted and um i
imagine sarah wilcox will be um
contacted i find um
just difficulty of getting through um
just general connection is an issue as
well so we'll deal with that council a
muller
thank you
yeah i also totally agree with what
kansas river has said i think it's
really really important that the
well the internet is up to date so that
members of the public can see exactly
what's happening sort of in lifetime etc
really really important otherwise wrong
information goes out which is not good
and it doesn't reflect well on the
council if that happened so yeah totally
support what
counts are you going to say thank you
okay thank you and i can see various
other nods um
and regarding financial things um
mandy has noted and we will um that will
go through to melissa
um who will answer the committee
personally we've been told
yes she she she's a bit sick at the
moment but when she gets out of bed and
is running again um we'll um enact that
councillor norman
i'm sorry just to come back on that just
another point as well and with the
council's associate social media
presence i find that depending on which
social media you use the information
differs i don't find that they're often
like concurrent with each other if that
makes sense obviously if some people are
using like facebook they'll get certain
information if somebody's on twitter
they'll get others so just lining that
up just to make sure obviously they're
both kind of the same if that makes
sense just because i know sort of
equally people that use just one or the
other so obviously it's just a good way
of getting the information out there so
just something to bear in mind that was
all i'm not sure if that's question for
here or communications team but i just
thought i'd just say in the meeting
some things are put on facebook and some
things but it's like they're not
different it's just like they're not
updated at the same time and they don't
always have the same things on there
um so it's yeah it was more of that
point it's not the information it's
different if it's on there if it's on
both but it's just yeah facebook will
get some updates twitter will get some
and they usually line up but not always
so it's just just something to monitor
so updated at different times is um it
is the problem is you see it summer's
out of date you're saying yes yeah yeah
okay well that will be um highlighted as
well
any other points or questions before we
go to debate
no okay
well the government the governance
statement um it encompasses everything
and i'm really happy with it
if we can live up to all that it'll be
fantastic
whether we do or not is um
it may be a moot point we've got to try
hard and sometimes there's difficulties
but happy to um
to accept a proposal to move forward to
that because um
that's the basis of what we do and it's
it's absolutely excellent councilman
you're making a proposal for the
recommendations on page 39 i'm more than
happy to second those yeah well i i will
propose um
so
unless other debate will go to the vote
country reborn yes
um thank you thank you chair i note that
the
recommendation says for
3.3 further that approve of any
significant amendments
um be delegated blah blah blah to the
but the
um officer mentioned isn't actually i
mean as you can watch this on youtube
but isn't actually in this meeting and
and i'm
i'm not particularly happy with it i'm
i'm pleased there's points about
realistic budgets and so on
so forth been made but the issues about
um
how we show budget setting by the
community the um intranet um
website and the issue about
communications um unless
i've got assurance that those are going
to be looked at before this is signed
off it says it's going to be
um signed off by the leader of each
council then i
you know i don't want to have to vote
against it but i don't want to vote in
favor of it unless i'm con
unless i have assurance that those
issues are being picked up thank you
chair
well i assume we could give you that
insurance is that is that a correct john
if it's noted and we've actioned
somebody to look at these things is that
um
is that progress enough for you
yeah i think if i you know have
assurance i wouldn't want to then go and
look at final version and see nothing's
changed is what you know because we we
have all made comments
thank you
if i can just
chair what i can do with obviously
mandy's help with the recording of the
notes i can go back to those relevant
offices and ask them to either clarify
or
amend the words in such a way that we
will be looking at moving forward and
that can be a revised
ags
so my intention is once that's signed
off if you if you're happy with that
counsellor
i can then get the two leaders obviously
and arthur then to sign it and my
intention is then to redistribute not
just to this
committee but the whole of the councils
because i think it's such an important
document that all members should have a
read and understand that so
if i go back and start to ask those
questions of those relevant officers
bearing in mind the discussions that
we've had today
hopefully they can make those initial
amendments i'll speak to emily when i
see her she's on leave at the moment as
well and then we can get that signed off
if that's um satisfied for this
committee's purposes
thank you thank you chairman
yes i see it's either that or proposed
an amendment but um this this seems a
good wipe down i would think
okay thank you with no other points
we'll move um
to the vote mandy please thank you chair
that vote is now in progress on the app
councillor norman
thank you
the chair that's eight votes for so
that's unanimous
thank you
all right thank you everybody
and now we do move to paper 2133 the
annual treasury report um
sue palmer please
thank you chair
this is the joint treasury management
report covering the position for the
eight turn for the financial year
2021-22
it provides details of the performance
effects of decisions taken during that
period
and confirms compliance with the
council's treasury management policy
the report explains in more detail the
factors affecting the strategy and
activities
including the regulatory framework
economic conditions
interest rate and liquidity risk
major issues over the period
were the economic recovery from the
coronavirus pandemic
the war in ukraine
higher inflation and higher interest
rates
cpi was 0.7
in march 2021
but thereafter began to steadily
increase
surges in wholesale gas and electricity
prices led to cpi for february 2022
as 6.2 year-on-year up from the 5.5 in
the previous month
bank rate was
0.1 at the beginning of the reporting
period however to combat rising
inflation the bank of england increased
it to 0.75
by march 2022
the government's furlough scheme had
insulated the labour market from the
worst effects of the pandemic
having peaked at 5.2 percent in december
2020 unemployment continued to fall
and the labor market data for the three
months to january 2022 showed the
unemployment rate at 3.9 percent
more specifically for our two councils
both councils continue to hold
additional cash from government grants
received relating to covid19
this has increased treasury investment
activity during the year
regarding banking activities both
councils operated within the daily bank
limits
except for one occasion when baba
exceeded its daily limit as mentioned in
appendix c paragraph 4.1
each council has decreased its debt baby
by 6.7 million
and mid suffolk by 7.2 million
mid suffolk lent a further 4.5 million
to gateway 14.
all investment activities undertaken
were in accordance with the approved
counterparty list
except for one occasion when
mid-suffolk exceeded its investment
limits in two of its money market funds
by 500 000 each
as mentioned in appendix c paragraph 4.1
the position was resolved the next day
the process notes
included overall limits but not
individual fund limits
so the process has been revised and
updated to include individual fund
balances as part of the approval process
the council's investment activities
including average returns can be found
in appendix c of the report
both councils are compliant with the
upper limits for interest rate exposure
the investment activity undertaken for
the year was done so in priority order
of security and liquidity over yield as
prescribed in the treasury management
strategy
and if you have any questions i'll be
happy to answer them and if there's any
i can't answer today then i'll then
melissa will get back to you as soon as
she's able to after the committee
i presume the general rise in interest
rates is going to be
detrimental for us i presume is it just
um
at the moment is continuing to go up i
know we earn money but we also
pay for what we've borrowed is that
correct assumption
yes the
gap between the
interest receivable and interest payable
will continue yes
okay
questions from the floor please
um thank you very much chair um
just a couple of things please um one
the prudential code changed um a couple
of years ago and we've chosen not to um
adopt it until 2023-24
um
why not um this is to do with the
you know
um
government changes they've made with
regards to pwlb borrowing and and so on
so why did we not just
um adopt it for this financial year and
i appreciate this financially as started
but why do we not do that
on the
environmental implications of this
report it refers to
recommending that the cabinet pushes its
fund managers to filter invest
investments in respect of
esg as in environmental social and
government considerations
so i just wonder what that
what we mean by pushing kind of thing
there
and um
finally third question if i may when we
talk about trading companies um
paragraph 2.7 refers to the um
sorry not 2.7 2.6
refers to the holdings companies
that um where we're holding equity
and just could you advise where this the
scrutiny of those holdings companies
will be and how that's communicated
how the information in 2.6 is
communicated to the full council thank
you thank you
yes thank you councillor evonne um
the middle one service something that i
sort of did ask and query about in the
briefing as well and would have done if
rachel hunter got him first so maybe if
you can some reassurance um
on that position please
thank you
uh yes well the credential code i've
changed the 2023-25 obviously the next
strategy that we prepare will be for 23
24 so we will take into account all the
changes in the prudential code
we did acknowledge uh that
you know the changes in the pwrb
arrangements
uh regarding borrowing for commercial
activities
we um
completed the investment in cifco
in 2021 20 sorry
2020-21 so we're not doing any new
investment in civco so
um
we won't be uh falling foul of the
prudential code there
um so we kind of have adopted that part
of it if you like so the rest will say
be covered by the the next strategy that
we
prepare for 2023
can i just come in there sorry because
in that case what why did we not just
adopt it for
22-23 why wait another year is my you
know
if if it's out there another you know
what was the problem in not adopting it
okay i think the the the rest of the
changes were around reporting and um i
think the
um some of those reporting will be
there'll be more reporting
um so it's more preparing uh
more sort of an administration point of
view really so sort of a practical point
of view if you like so yeah
yes
yes thank you
um as regards the position on the esg
investments
we currently have the investments in the
pooled funds
and we try to diversify across various
areas
um the
ccla for example
this is the first year where we've
actually had a
a valuation that's actually slightly
more than the investment that we put in
originally
but the ccla is a property fund
the other funds are multi-asset funds
so they do they are spread wider
at the moment they're still below the
investment level
um so it wouldn't be a good idea at the
moment to pull out of those investments
um the primary aim of those investments
was actually to generate you know income
to support the revenue budget
um which they are doing
so the the position is is under you know
monitoring uh constant monitoring really
so
yes it was you know subject to all these
external factors so
um
do you want to if i can just come back
on that i wasn't you know i know
previously in this committee's discuss
pulling out of particular funds i wasn't
um suggesting that i just saying that i
just wasn't sure what the words pushing
meant in that paragraph we're pushing
fund managers does that mean they're
assessing them
very regularly does that mean um this
count this council these councils have
said we want to you know we've got an
ultimate aim what does what does that
mean that's what i was trying to get to
thank you
i think it just means to keep monitoring
it and and at the right time to to
review it and take necessary
decisions
thank you
and your third question regarding the
trading companies i'll just um is that
an appendix
could you point it to the page please
yes it's on page 106 um
paragraph 2.6
um where it refers to the equity in
in the suffolk holdings
and um my question was whether
how is that you know obviously we see
pacifica business plans but how is that
the holding company equity issues
communicated to council and what is the
scrutiny of that
that fund that um
holding thank you yeah
um the
board
reports to
committee
committee members
and
even one of the recent internal audits
has been around the company's side
from you know the council side looking
at how the the companies perform and
their governance arrangements and
everything else
look
puzzled about rachel's um middle
question we do have quite a bit of money
in spread
bonds and some of that is in
maybe fossil fuel companies or things
that aren't particularly environmentally
friendly and there's been questions
raised of how ethical
that is at the present time so
that was the bones of the question we've
got
spread bonds in lots of things including
maybe some things that um
maybe it's not good to invest in at the
moment but we would have to take the
whole lot out to get it out of a certain
percentage of it that is the problem and
um
i think rachel was asking um are we
really pushing or
or just waiting and um
you know i've got a strong view about
that i think maybe we should push a bit
harder but we'll visit that another time
in fairness
to sue um
there's a difference in pushing and just
waiting and some of them may never get
up to what we invested so um
they may not they may never come back to
what or or take a long time in which
case um there's a bit of
uncomfortableness with their amongst
some of our committee
just to bring everybody up to date with
what we're actually talking about
councillor davis
please
thank you chair um
as you know i'm very new to this a
particular subject
i've uh a background in business so when
i see a snapshot like this
it um
i also appreciate a lot of work has gone
into it however
it would be helpful if it's possible to
give at least the previous year or
possibly two so we can see what the
trend is because seeing a snapshot like
this
without the background it's difficult to
see where the uh
the organization is heading
so my
first question
um
second one is all for the tangent do we
hedge
against interest rate rises or or not
no
well that's simple
i mean we invent we invest or borrow at
the best rates we can at the time
we use uh treasury advisors all in close
and and um
uh brokers as well who are you know sort
of commissioned to find the best rates
for us
uh but that's as far as we go
and then um sort of a general
observation there seems to be quite a
difference between
what the budgeted expenditure was and
what the actual expenditure is
on a good number of things by quite a
significant margin
like millions of pounds
so i was wondering
why that is
okay
the
the borrowing
that we do is often to support is to
support like the capital program that
kind of thing and
um
we've had there's been various delays in
the capital program due to supply issues
and you know the general
econo economic situation that we're in
so
that has impacted on what we've needed
to borrow and what we've been able to
invest
we've had government grants come in
which we've been able to invest
we had some coming right at the end of
march so
we were able to invest that or reduce
our borrowing so that can impact on you
know how we've originally budgeted or
how it looks against the budget
as regards the sort of interest
receivable and payable
um
because so we haven't
had such a significant capital programme
um then we haven't had to borrow so much
therefore we haven't had so much
interest to pay
um
and likewise sort of the interest
receivable some of the returns haven't
been as good as we had expected so
um
there's
a difference in in the budget but or
created budget variances in that regard
so
this difference between budget and
actual if you look at the i think it's
page
29 for the hra
in mid suffolk
we're budgeting roughly 40 million and
we've
actually spent 14
so
that's 26 million difference
why
i probably got the different document
but anyway
page 29 but i may have the wrong
document i guess
thank you
um
so my concern is that we may not be
doing as much for our
our tenants as we had intended
yes it is yes
it's around the um
hr sort of development pipeline and the
capital program you know the new build
and the acquisitions that
that we had planned
some of those
schemes were delayed that there were
issues around
materials and
supplies
deliveries there were also i think some
you know around planning issues around
some of the schemes so they didn't
advance as quickly as we had expected i
mean they obviously still
ongoing schemes um but you know that
it's just delayed
um so therefore they
uh you know that that reflects that's
reflected in in a
um a lower than budget expenditure
thank you
so just a follow-up to that too so that
money that's not spent
that's invested in short-term um
investments is uh
uh yes wherever we can get the best
rates yes yes yes so it's yeah we're
aware of that um council of davis it
it's the money is always doing something
even sometimes overnight is that still
correct it goes somewhere to
be invested even for a very very short
time so
um what is the what is the sort of rate
on that sort of a weak investment it
must be virtually minuses or has it now
gone up with the increase
it has gone up a little bit yes
yes
as the bank rate has been increasing
then
our investment rates have gone up a
little bit as well yes yeah
we did deal with this councillor davis
at another time and um
every penny
that we have in our possession is trying
to earn um
you know a dollar somewhere at all the
time
you know i'm not saying that sue sits up
playing the stock market but um it's
always put somewhere safe and where it
is earning a little so
that is very good to know
right that's right i appreciate that but
my concern is one where
we may have a program to upgrade or
maintain the properties under the hra
and we have discontented
residents who are expecting something to
happen
that hasn't happened so that that's i'm
confident that we invest the money we
have yes wisely no problem
it's the other end of it yes i can see
yes yeah thank you yeah well i think it
always happens but maybe not in in
in time in this sort of market it's a
bit like that i'm afraid but um yes as
long as we've got insurance that
everyone's working to make it happen um
that's probably the best we can do
okay before we go today any more
questions on clarification on what we
have before us
no let's move to debate then please
um look we're looking for several
proposals and seconded on this so
any further comments
uh councillor davis
i just like to say thank you for
switching from short-term to medium-term
investments in mid-suffolk
that was
good rights fix thank you
i'll feed that back to the team thank
you
anyone wants to enter into a debate or
any comments on the papers
no well i think then we ought to move to
um
proposing second and there are three
papers that's correct doesn't it to be
um
yes chair so we will be having three
votes on this item and so
recommendations um
3.1 and 3.2 is for everybody to vote on
and so i will need a proposal and a
second year for that first
well i would propose to
propose on the first one and look for a
second which could be from anywhere
mid-south
anyone anyone wish to second that okay
yep
okay so uh
so that vote is now open for everybody
to vote on
sorry counselor norman
thank you
okay so that was eight votes for so
that's unanimous
so
the next vote is for recommendation 3.3
which is for baby members only
so if i could have a proposal
a council of nun
thank you very much
another
for the councillor norman thank you
okay so that vote is now open for baby
members only please
sorry councillor norman
thank you
so that is uh
let's make sure i've got everybody so
that's four votes four so that is
unanimous
and then
uh recommendation 3.4 is for mid-suffolk
members
if i can have a proposed council in
murray thank you
thank you and councillor davis to second
thank you both okay so that date is now
open for mid-suffolk members only
[Applause]
and that is four votes four so that's
your anonymous as well chair
that's all the boats
okay thank you everybody and the last
item on the agenda today um 2134 the
forward plan
which is for noting or adding to or if
anyone feels strongly about anything
country reborn yes um thank you chair i
just wondered about um if we were
looking at commissioning and procurement
at some point
um
because i know there's been a lot of
changes to that i don't know how that
fits in
because i understand there's been some
changes and looking forward to for
forward planning in terms of what needs
to be done i just wondered whether that
was something that will be coming to
this committee thank you
it's not on here at all at the moment is
it but you would like it to come on
um is that something sue that you could
answer is is that your sort of field
no sorry i don't know between anything
i think chair that it was something that
that melissa evans had been looking at
and i if she'd been here obviously i
could have asked her directly but
because it's been raised as over time as
an issue i just wasn't sure
whether it was expected to come here but
if someone could just check that that
would be helpful thank you yes
i'll take that to melissa outside of the
meeting yes okay
is there a particular issue with that
councilory bond that you want clarity on
i think it's just the fact here that
because it's been looked at and there
was it was had been identified i think
well probably more than a year ago a
couple of years ago that there were
it needed um
that there needed to be some changes in
the way that it was being done and so on
and that there was a project to do to
look at that that was just given that is
quite intrinsic to kind of the
the finances and the processes within
the organizations i just thought that
that
you know
whether either if it had been melissa
here we could have had an update or i
could have asked her directly but um
if that is
some area
you know obviously it's been raised in
internal audit as well so whether it's
something that we
would be looking at okay thank you
country reborn will get an opinion and
if it needs to come to this committee um
it will do i would think i think melissa
will um
probably write
to us as a committee on these matters
that we've struggled a bit on and um
we'll get a view
well in time for the next meeting
any other points on the forward plan
no everybody's happy there's some quite
big
beefy bits of work coming up for the
rest of the um
electoral year so um we will be busy
okay well i think that brings the
meeting to a close thank you
soon john for attending and for ben
i'm sure we all will wish middles a
speedy road to recovery um and the next
meeting is on the 26th of september
you